i mean patrick i mean patrick mahomes
just did sign the biggest
you know contract in american history
what is it
i think the the deal overall is worth
500 million over 10
what
oh my god and then then dak prescott for
the cowboys they've been trying to do a
long-term deal
that's how crazy things are getting they
offered him a guaranteed
you know i think it's like four years
100 million dollars guaranteed he turned
it down
what first hundred million dollar
contract turned down the nfl
how do you turn that down he thinks he
can make more so what they're gonna do
if you don't come into the deal
what teams can do is they're gonna apply
to the franchise tax who have to pay the
highest
you know so he'll make so it's a
one-year deal they franchise tag
him he'll make like 33 million this year
let's just show you how rare of an
athlete he is i guess right
how reliable so i showed you the market
it shows you the market for a good
quarterback and
to me he's not even a top 10 guy you
know he's never really
no he's never won a playoff game he has
the best o line in the [ __ ]
in the world he has the best run running
back some would say is good defense good
coaching
and he goes eight and eight or nine and
seven doesn't win a playoff game so it's
like
damn damn it's so fascinating
no wonder you wanted to be a pro
football player though because if you do
get that service no
no no see that that's the problem that's
like saying i want to be a comedian
because kevin hart makes 100 million
yeah of course of course what you're
looking at
you're going oh i want to be a football
player because patrick mahomes makes 500
million in 10 years
no no dude most of those players are
in and out of the league in two and a
half years three years and that's
they
he's been on his rookie contract for the
past
i want to say four years he's been with
the dallas cowboys
in total from the cowboys he's made 2.7
million dollars
that's it that's it man so you got to
pay taxes that's not
doing no you're not you now don't get me
wrong he has outside incentives and
endorsement deals like campbell soup and
stuff but
you know if on your rookie deal you're
not making a ton of money man you got to
prove yourself and that's why patrick
mahomes
you know they think he's the future and
he's going to be the greatest ever
they paid what he's worth but
but a lot of you know most guys are
making those crazy crazy deals
because a lot of it you know i guess
there's more guaranteed money now
thanks to their nfl players association
but basketball and baseball is
guaranteed money son
so if i play for the nuggets one game
and i signed a
four-year deal for 200 million dollars
and i roll my ankle
or i break my leg you owe me 200 [ __ ]
million dollars dude
really yeah the mets are still paying
bobby bonilla
what yeah from like so so but football
football if you get injured
you get damn football's nothing's
guaranteed like
when you sight like that's what's crazy
about dax's contract i can't believe he
signed it he didn't sign it
they guaranteed him a million dollars
dude a hundred million dollars take
money
take that [ __ ] money well what he's
saying is
uh i'll take the franchise tag so pay me
whatever 32 million this year
with my endorsement deals i'll probably
make another 10 million
and then if you want in french and not
give me another big deal next year
you have to franchise tag me again which
would be another 40-something million
dollars she's like
so i'm gonna make about the same without
signing this long-term deal
how long is the deal for 109 i think it
was four or five years it
seemed like a good deal again i don't
think he's that great man
sign the [ __ ] deal yep
i don't know man i know because with
football you can get hurt so easily
now the one thing about dax is he
doesn't get hurt he's never missed a
game he's healthy
big guy sturdy like i think six
two two thirty like sturdy a lot of it's
also having an eye periphery vision see
when the storm when somebody's coming
and being able to protect
i think that was peyton manning's uh his
gift was
his ability to kind of see before other
people could see when he was about to
hit and then brace himself that's it
if you get hit blind side you get [ __ ]
up well yeah
and just other professionals everyone
knows that but the same with like
the same with like time wow uh anyways
tom brady like but but again like tom
brady was so good at it because he
didn't want to get rid of the ball he
didn't take big hits
prescott again he has the besso line in
the league man he's the best running
back in the league so there's not that
much pressure to get the job done
peyton manning had great offensive lines
he had great receivers great running
backs
tom brady had you know he had he had a
good team man great coaching great
game plan stuff like that yeah
yeah the thing i just wanna i gotta
start working on my footwork and my
[ __ ] release
dude cause i wanna make some money i
know dude i was watching patrick my
homes using this celebrity golf thing
and you know live sports i'll watch
anything at this [ __ ] point
so they had patreon homes on there they
had i
think maybe drew brees was playing john
smoltz they had some other
oh uh steph curry was playing but i was
you could tell like
like patrick jones was a guy who knew
how knows he's making 500 million
dollars he's like
hitting the ball like whoa you know like
i think you think how good he must feel
[ __ ] amazing well why because he won
the super bowl he was super
mvp and then just signed a 10-year deal
worth 500 million the biggest
he's also a good-looking dude and he's
got the whole world
football players again i i don't have
direct experience that
but when you're up an all-star football
player you're basically a god
i mean you're basically uh you're you're
you've been treated like a
prince since you were
16. well before that i mean if you're
for that
if you're if in uh you know pop one or
little league or
if you're a freshman in high school and
you're on varsity you're stunned it's
so if you're adrian adrian peterson
you've been you've been treated like
like just uh loyalty man you know
truly like he like yeah you're just a
hero everywhere you walk oh and by the
way you're a stud you're also a great
looking dude
not all of them but yeah i mean hey i
need you
so you've been watching ballers i need
you to calm down because that's an older
show too
so i need you to calm down and they have
the rock i think the rock's an agent in
it so you gotta calm down
i won't calm down and i'll say something
about the rock his acting is
he could have used all due respect i
love the road hold on hold on before you
carry on he's the highest paid actor of
all time go i understand i just
i just he could have used a little brian
callum he could use this
workshop yeah i would have just little
tweaks i would have just
have you seen him in like jumanji or
like he's great
he's a great actor i think enough i
think he's just
coasting in that [ __ ] show i think
he was so busy that he just had time to
show up and do his lines
i really do that's what i have yeah
i mean he was doing everything i don't
know how he [ __ ] did a tv show
because that's
that tv show there's a lot and he's
there all day i can guarantee it
because i can see how they shot it and
it's actually heavy acting it's not
easy so he had he was doing all these
movies and that
that's that's a heavy load man that's a
heavy load so considering
that's what i mean is i could see he was
clearly probably exhausted
probably like didn't have time to do ten
takes
and just was like let's go you know yeah
but yet you love the show so sure yeah i
love the show and i love the rock so it
doesn't really matter yeah
you'll play this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected